You know what really bugs me?
(dramatic music)
(laughs) Okay, okay that was dumb. I'm sorry.
No, what really bugs me is..
(dramatic music)
(laughs)
You didn't think I'd do it again, did you?
Okay okay, I'll stop, I'll stop for real, I won't do it again.
I won--maybe sometime later, but whatever.
What really bugs me
is when you're talking to a friend,
and they drop this at the end of the conversation:
(gasp) Oh my god, did you hear about John?
No, what happened?
Oh my god, it was so cray.
What was it?
It's just..heart wrenching stuff.
What?
Heart wrenching? No,
heart shattering.
WHAT
HAPPENED?
Well..
I'll tell you later.
What? Why?
Why can't you just..tell me right now,
while we're talking?
I mean, I could understand if
it was like a high-stake situation
and there was no time..
Looks like this is it.
Yeah.
It's been great working with you, partner.
You too.
And now that we're gonna die together,
there's something I've always wanted to tell you.
What is it?
I've always wanted you to know that..
Wait!
I knew my paper clip quirk would come in handy!
I'm out!
Wait, Arden, what were you gonna say?
Be quiet, I need to concentrate
if I'm going to defuse this.
I'll tell you later.
(beeping)
Dude, what were you gonna tell me, it's killing me!
Arden: Will you shut up,
I am trying to defuse this bomb!
You can't just say that you're gonna say
something and leave me hanging, dude.
That is messed up!
That is messed up, what if we die?!
You shut up--
(screams)
That? I can totally understand that.
But usually when someone says,
"I'll tell you later,"
it's when they have time to totally
tell you what's going on.
And I don't understand it. Do they just not wanna
get into a super long story at the moment?
Do they want to hype it up?
Do they enjoy the torture aspect of it?
I know.
Why?
I'll tell you later.
I'm Anna Akana.
Stay awesome Gotham.
So, you may have noticed my fabulous
fashion throughout today's video.
I wanna say thank you to LootCrate for the loot,
and for sponsoring today's episode.
So LootCrate is this monthly subscription
box that you can give to yourself,
your friends, or even your pets!
Today's pieces are from their LVLUP crate,
which delivers epic phantom apparel.
My favorite is this Mario scarf because
it matches my cat furniture decor.
(purrs)
Be sure to sign up for next month's crate,
because the theme is:
(high singing)
The deadline is July 19th, 9:00PM Pacific,
and be sure to go to lootcrate.com/anna,
and use the offer code "ANNA" for 10% off at checkout.